You remember prime numbers right?
Numbers that can only be evenly divided by
one and themselves?
Well it turns out finding prime numbers is
not only useful for protecting data, but it
could make you money!
On December 26th, 2017, the largest prime
number ever discovered was found by Jonathan
Pace of Germantown, Tennessee.
The number is over 23 million digits long,
meaning I don’t really have time in this
video or my entire life to list the whole
thing out, but it’s easier to call it by
its nickname, M77232917.
It gets this name because that’s the exponent
you raise 2 by to find it.
Oh, and don’t forget to subtract one when
you’re done multiplying 77,232,917 twos
together.
Otherwise you just created a number you can
divide by two and you’ll have wasted all
that time.
Prime numbers found this way, by raising two
by a prime exponent and subtracting one, are
called Mersenne primes, named for a 17th century
French friar, hence the capital “M” in
the shorthand name.
3 is a Mersenne prime, since it’s two to
the second power minus one.
Same for 7, which is two to the third power
minus one.
But the exponent has to be prime.
Two to the sixth power minus one is 63, which
is divisible by 3 so, not a prime.
9 of the 10 largest primes found to date are
Mersenne primes, not because they’re the
most common -- the Prime Number theorem tells
us there must be a simply huge number of undiscovered
primes between this newly found one and the
next largest Mersenne prime -- but we find
them because that’s how we keep searching
for them.
In fact you can be a part of the search for
the next one!
You don’t even have to do the math yourself,
just some software provided by the Great Internet
Mersenne Prime Search, or GIMPS!
The software uses the idle processing power
of your CPU to run what’s called the Lucas-Lehmer
test, where Mersenne numbers are checked against
a specific set of numbers.
If the Mersenne number you’re checking divides
evenly into a certain number in that set,
then it passes the test and is indeed a prime
number.
Obviously it takes quite a bit of horsepower
to see if a 23 million digit number divides
into an even bigger number, which is why the
project needs the public’s help.
Almost 200,000 users are running the GIMPS
software and if their PC runs a number that
passes the test, they could win money.
Pace is eligible for a $3,000 prize, and whoever
finds a 100 million digit prime could win
$150,000 dollars.It’s like cryptocurrency
mining for those of us that can’t afford
to buy a dozen graphics cards.
You may wonder why we bother searching for
primes at all?
Why for the glory, of course!
We’ve only found 50 Mersenne Primes and
next to almost every one of them is the finder’s
name for all of nerdy eternity.
Plus prime numbers play a crucial role in
keeping data secure.
One standard, RSA encryption, relies on multiplying
two large prime numbers together to generate
a key.
Knowing the two primes that went into the
key is the secret to decrypting the data,
but it takes an impractical amount of computational
power and time to suss out what those numbers
are if you don’t already know them.
So the key can be public and your data is
still secure.
Of course since the Mersenne primes we’ve
been finding lately are tens of millions of
digits long, these may not be the best candidates
for encryption.
If you see a key that’s an absolutely huge
number, it won’t be hard to guess which
Mersenne prime went into it.
Gigantic primes won’t be useful until quantum
computing is used to break RSA encryption,
and even then we may just use a different
method of protecting data.
So there may not be much practical use in
searching for Mersenne primes, aside from
winning that $150,000 for running a program
while you watch youtube.
I gotta download that software when I get
home.
Before you run off and download GIMPS, go
ahead and subscribe.
And for more math, find out how ham sandwiches
are helping us understand the universe, here.
The largest prime found by hand is M127, so
we’re obviously a bit past that by now.
Until next time, I’m Julian, don’t forget
to share that sweet prize money with me when
you win.